this is sal here with rick hassan who's
a professor of law at uc irvine school
of law specializing in election law i'm
here with bradley smith who's former
chairman of the federal election
commission he's also a professor of law
at capital university in columbus ohio
and
runs the center for competitive politics
so we're here to talk about
what seems like a very important supreme
court case citizens united versus
federal election commission in 2010.
could you give a little bit of
background on what got us to this
supreme court decision
the
federal government specifically congress
gets to pass laws that regulate
the financing of federal elections and
then for state and local elections that
would be an issue for each state and so
congress for actually going back more
than a century has passed laws limiting
the amount of money kinds of money
uh that can be raised what has to be
disclosed it passed a whole bunch of
laws and these laws are sometimes
challenged
uh as being unconstitutional the usual
challenge is that
the law violates part of the first
amendment which protects
freedom of speech and association
and the specific issue in the citizens
united case
uh had to do with the
first amendment rights of
corporate corporations
to spend money to support or oppose
candidates for federal office well it is
an important case but it is a widely
misunderstood case
the case for example is not about the
question of whether
quote corporations are people we
sometimes hear that not a single justice
on the court in any of the opinions
addresses that issue because it's a
long-standing doctrine of corporate
personhood that corporations have
certain rights
certain rights that people have when
they join together to associate the
case is not about the question of
whether money equals speech the court
has long held not that money is speech
but that you can't try to limit an
activity which would be protected under
the constitution like speech by limiting
money for example you could not say it
shall be illegal to spend any money in
the united states to publish a book or
to pay an author or to operate a
bookstore right so if you were
say general motors or
google and
you wanted to put an ad online or on tv
or in a newspaper that says
support president smith for re-election
that would be illegal if it was paid for
with
money from the corporation corporations
could still participate
but they'd have to set up a separate
committee called a political action
committee or pac
and they could only solicit certain
uh people to put money into that pack
and they couldn't take money that they
made from selling cars or software or
something like that and use it for
political purposes and in citizens
united uh reversing some earlier cases
the supreme court said
that
corporations like individuals have a
first amendment right to spend
independently
supporting our opposing candidates for
office and that
it would be
unconstitutional to limit this because
it would be too much of an infringement
on the speech rights of corporations
it's about what rights people have
to engage in speech when they have
chosen to organize as a corporation so
the court makes the holding that
corporations and unions have uh
constitutional protection under the
first amendment when they make
independent expenditures to advocate for
the election or defeat of candidates and
by independent expenditures we don't say
that they can contribute money directly
to candidate campaigns but they are free
to spend their own money to communicate
with the public at large and say we
think you should vote for this candidate
or against this candidate for these
reasons uh and and that i think in a
nutshell is what the case
is about at that highest level
so just to get a little bit more into
the case it's really all around this
bipartisan campaign reform act the
mccain feingold act of 2002 what was all
that about and then how did that lead
eventually to this supreme court
decision of citizens united versus
federal election commission well in some
ways it goes goes back much further than
the bipartisan campaign reform act we
should note that congress in in 1907
passed the first federal statute that
limited uh corporate contributions to
campaigns right
but corporations quickly found out well
we can just do expenditures we don't
contribute to the campaign we just spend
our own money but within this framework
both corporations and unions could do a
lot of things for example they could run
ads that said things like
you know congressman jones is a no-good
anti-worker worker lying
you know person who wants to destroy
american industry call congressman jones
and tell him we don't need his agenda in
washington and that didn't count as a
campaign expenditure because it didn't
specifically urge people to vote for or
against a candidate so president bush
signed a law president george w bush
signed a law
called the bipartisan campaign reform
act and this was in
2002 i believe it was
and it's commonly known as the
mccain-feingold law because those were
the two big senate sponsors
and um
the national rifle association senator
mcconnell a bunch of people sued and
argued it was unconstitutional while the
case was going through the courts the
national rifle association which
definitely has a political point of view
set up a satellite radio station called
nra news
and they said oh well if news
organizations can engage in this
unlimited kind of electoral activity
we'll just make ourselves a news
organizations
and many people thought this was going
to be a kind of sham way of just running
at political ads all the time well what
happened was that the nra news actually
started
having
news programs opinion programs call-in
programs not just on the election but on
issues that would matter to people who
were sympathetic to the nra and it
actually became a bona fide news
organization so the mccain-feingold law
or the bipartisan campaign reform act as
it's officially known attempted to close
this legister perceived loophole
by saying okay a corporation can't or
union can't even mention a candidate uh
in a broadcast dad
uh within 60 days of a general election
or within 30 days of a primary election
so enter a group called citizens united
citizens united is a an ideological
group
that is doing political activity still
around
and they had made a documentary
called hillary the movie
uh this was coming out at the time not
of the
past election that we just had
but back in 2008 in that period when
hillary clinton and barack obama were
going to be competing for the nomination
for the democratic nomination uh to be
president in the 2008 period
and
citizens united
is a non-profit corporation that is
they're not selling shoes they're just
using the corporate form to be able to
engage in associational activity
and there had already been a rule
well before the supreme court had
established which said if you're an
ideological corporation
and you don't take money from for-profit
companies
you can already spend whatever money you
have in your treasury on political uh
ads and political activity but citizens
united
deliberately
took money from for-profit corporations
and they did it because they were trying
to set up a test case what they wanted
to do was to take this documentary they
had made hillary the movie which said
very negative things about hillary
clinton
and they wanted to pay comcast cable
a million dollars to make this
movie available
as a video on demand which anyone could
watch by choosing it from the you know
the guide on their cable guide they'd be
able to watch it
and under the federal statute the
federal election commission said this
looks like it's a
uh it's going to be
on television
broadcasting the period close to the
election and it's going to feature the
name hillary clinton who's a candidate
for president
that would make it an election ad cannot
be paid for by corporate funds there
were lots of ways that the supreme court
could have gone aside from overturning
earlier cases
uh but the court was bold here and on a
five to four vote the liberals on the
court against the conservatives the
conservatives won
and the the um
the
long-standing federal prohibition on
corporations and labor unions as well
spending money in federal elections uh
fell
so just as a kind of a lay citizen you
know on the face of it i i understand
why there's all of this congressional
legislation you're afraid of undue
influence from uh corporations but you
know we were able to talk to a few
experts who i think took a more
sympathetic view to the supreme court
ruling and the point their point was is
you know citizens united was this
organization it definitely had an
ideological point of view and it was
making uh this content uh that was
clearly anti-hillary clinton
but there's many uh organizations media
organizations
you know i think we could point to news
channels websites which most people
would consider to be news organizations
or media organizations that do
definitely lean one way or the other
left or right and they they are arguing
that the reason why the supreme court
had to rule this way is if if what
citizens united wasn't allowed then
whether you're talking about an msnbc or
fox news or
that that would start putting them under
scrutiny well the law that limited what
corporations can do
created an exemption for
uh press organizations that were engaged
in journalistic kinds of activities
and indeed the majority in the court
said yeah we have to treat them the same
the justices expressed real concern
about the the nature of the government's
argument they said you know you're
saying it's just you can limit broadcast
ads but what about internet could you
limit communications about candidates
over the internet
and
the
government attorneys eventually said yes
we can we can limit anything that
involves a corporation speaking
about a candidate for office whether
it's on the internet or whatever and
by the time the oral argument was over
the government had asserted that it
would have the right for example to
limit the publication of a book that
included one line of advocacy urging
people to vote for a candidate at the
very end of a long you know 500 page
book they had suggested that they could
prohibit a union from publishing a
pamphlet that advocated the election of
a candidate you could envision you know
candidates something like you know why
working americans should support you
know hillary clinton for president or
something like that
they had suggested
that
books over kindle could be uh
banned under existing law and so the
supreme court said all right
this is very problematic to us
they scheduled it for a second oral
argument heard the case again and at the
end of the case said you know we don't
think that this is right at least a
majority did said you cannot limit the
speech of
a group of people or
or body
simply because it is incorporated
but there was an argument of the
dissenters that said the press is
different the press serves an
educational and informative function
which is different than the function of
other corporations and it's permissible
maybe in part because the constitution
does provide separate protection for the
press and that's a big debate about what
that means
that to carve this out
now that does create an inconsistency
we'd be saying we're going to treat
google one way and fox news and the new
york times another but the current law
is also inconsistent so let me give you
an example from the other side which i
think is very hard for those who support
citizens united to answer
in a case that came a couple of years
after citizens united
there was a guy who was a he was a
canadian law student then he became a
a lawyer in new york he went to harvard
law school
worked in new york and he uh he was here
on a work visa
and he wanted to
um
according to his complaint that he filed
he wanted to go to kinko's uh and
make flyers spend 50 cents making flyers
saying
re-elect president obama and he wanted
to hand those flyers out in central park
well because he was not a citizen
uh even though he's in the the united
states and has other kinds of first
member rights even though he's not
assistant he would violate federal law
he could go to jail for years face ten
thousand dollar fine if he hands that
piece of paper to one person because
then he'd be engaging in election
related activities a non-citizen
and this case went up and the supreme
court had a chance to explain why
as it said it says united if the
identity of the speaker doesn't matter
and the first amendment really is always
about more speech all the time in
elections why is it that this guy
benjamin blumen could be shut up and the
supreme court
didn't even hear the case
it came up on a special kind of appeal
from a three-judge court
which means that when the court declined
to hear the case it agreed
that the lower court was right that this
law is constitutional so we now have
this new anomaly which is that
we say that non-human entities
these corporations that only exist
because the state allows you to create
this this fake thing
non-human entities have these first
amendment rights but yet a human being
who is living in new york who wants to
spend 50 cents he couldn't do that and
so what's the difference uh if it's
really true that the identity of the
speaker doesn't matter which is what the
supreme court said is citizens united
well certainly the identity of the
speaker matters when that speaker is a
foreign individual or a foreign
government or a foreign corporation
so the it seems like the majority
opinion they're not saying that large
corporations being able to funnel tens
or hundreds of millions of dollars
for or against a campaign independently
of the the candidate that that won't
necessarily corrupt but it's more of
by trying to regulate it in the way that
the mccain feingold act does it actually
has far-reaching consequences uh or
trying to regulate it in the way that
the federal election commission was
trying to regulate it with citizens
united it has far-reaching consequences
that touch on just general free speech
issues like what you just talked about a
you know a sentence in a book that
happens to be published or sold during
the election or a movie made by a random
filmmaker i think for one thing for
example a lot of people again they they
say they resent this idea corporations
aren't people but they don't realize
corporations have always you know again
had some of these rights i acted as
corporations and uh and and acted in the
political arena in a variety of ways i
think what these people should ask
themselves is well if exxon were not
incorporated
would they go oh
well exxon's not incorporated well
that's fine let them spend all the money
they want right and and conversely i
find most of these people if you say
well should we be able to censor
the new york times it's a corporation
they say well no no no
not that and and and when you see that i
think it makes people realize the the
question is not really whether it's a
corporation speaking or not the question
is
whether or not we think the first
amendment protects the expenditure
of money we actually had to have rules
before citizens united to differentiate
because we actually this was the law
that
um google and general motors could not
spend their funds directly on election
speech but
the new york times and fox news could
and so we had tests and the federal
election commission had tests and there
are just some disagreements about how to
best do it i would point to the work of
professor sonja west at uh the
university of georgia has written
extensively on this and she said the
test should be people who are regularly
engaged in journalism that doesn't mean
it has to be objective and you can't
have a point of view it doesn't mean
there's a problem with fox news or msnbc
because they might have a point of view
but it means you're doing some something
other than electioneering i do think
that there's some sense yes that's what
i'm saying that these are these are some
of the cost of having a vibrant robust
first amendment and if you uh want to
give the government the power to
regulate you know books and movies you
should think about who is the politician
you most hate is it hillary clinton is
it donald trump is it you know somebody
else do you want them in charge of
deciding who gets to speak out in
politics and in what way and in what
fashion in what manner uh and and i
think you should think about it in those
terms and that might that sometimes
makes people realize may
be it's best to let things
go now i i would say however having said
that that a lot of the arguments about
corporate influence are are vastly
overblown there's a quite a bit of
debate really about whether or not
corporations in fact benefit uh from
spending money on politics uh
corporations big corporations the really
you know the fortune 500 types what they
really like to do is spend money on
lobbying uh that's much more direct uh
they can talk to candidates directly
they can let other people elect folks
there's almost certain to be some folks
elected who they will like and they can
go work with those people and craft
messages and bills and they can do this
more behind the scenes and that way they
don't have to offend any of their
customers who who don't like the party
that they're supporting but it's also
clear that that just spending money
doesn't automatically win elections uh
you can look at the last presidential
election i mean donald trump's been
about all told about a quarter of what
the hillary clinton forces spent it
certainly helps to have money uh but in
the end uh it's not dispositive what
what the monies does is it's spent to
try to inform voters and those voters go
out and vote at the polls
so we've learned that in citizens united
the supreme court ruled that political
spending by corporations associations
and labor unions is a form of protected
speech under the first amendment but
whether or how the government can limit
free speech and campaign contributions
is still a matter of debate
as rick hayson notes one test for the
difference between the free speech
rights accorded to journalists and those
of corporations might be whether they
are entities regularly engaged in
journalism but as bradley smith points
out allowing the government to impose
limits on how people or corporations
speak out in politics may lead to
unintended consequences
to learn more about citizens united
visit the national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics